regular smelling David now and I like
that I didn't realize how important have
you your own thing was like I I didn't
understand that concept because when
Bart and I were together everything was
online like our whole CUNY talk was
online and like a part of me never
wanted that to be online but I didn't
know why I didn't even know that I
didn't want that online oh I didn't
understand that I was just like
something about it just makes me feel
weird that you know it and I just
thought that I was embarrassed by it
that's what I thought it was I thought I
was embarrassed by people knowing that
we're like cute behind-the-scenes oh you
didn't want the know none of that I
wanted it all to be private I'm like a
very very private person for sure um and
I wanted it to be my thing and then once
it was revealed on my [ __ ] it's not
special anymore so I get where she's
coming from like in a relationship you
have to have your special bubble thing
mm-hmm so I get it like before I would
have judged Mariel and what I would have
been like damn she's [ __ ] controlling
yeah but now I'm like no that's like
your like personal love thing and that's
[ __ ] beautiful so do you guys have
something now that's not the the QT talk
that you do that's just for you guys
no it's just the horny sexy talk oh we
didn't have that before but now we have
weird sexy talk we had that before
um bro we were a [ __ ] mess man so we
were like soul mates madly in love that
moved quickly into business partners
mm-hmm that lurid like employee boss
relationship because I'm working with JK
that then quickly escalated to business
partners where we're now equals and all
we ever did was work work work so the
relationship was just on the back burner
and sex just kind of became one of those
things where it's like [ __ ] okay well I
can't shake this horniness wanna [ __ ]
okay let's do it and it was just like
like this just get it get it over with
so there was no real connection because
we weren't we weren't acting like a
couple because we didn't have anything
personal that was ours it was like like
let like this is just what he liked yeah
and they like let's just get it done so
yeah we didn't have any of that really
we [ __ ] we've come a long way man now
we're just we're the best we've ever
been so now we have that but you guys
have been together for such a long time
though yeah well you guys also did ask
the fee
so at the time when you guys were doing
ask the field wasn't like that as well
yeah I mean because we had like decent
sex it wasn't like horrible it was
pretty bad but but but as the fuel was
about arasta fields was about like just
your experiences your sexual experiences
so it wasn't necessarily just with him
like I've had other partners not just an
accumulation of stories and then also
just like my own fantasies were shared -
oh because I've never seen an episode of
ask the field yes please don't sounds a
little too much for me
like it it was like I it's it's
entertaining for you guys but I've known
these people for so [ __ ] long if I
have to listen to like 30 minutes of
like come talk for my people had known
for that long it's yeah it might be
funny here and there but it's a little
it's still a little weird for me
especially if you're not in the
conversation
I'm just voyeuristic Lee watching it's
weird yeah but if I was in the room it's
funny yeah but now I'm like I don't even
listen I can't even watch any of my
friends [ __ ] I can't do it because
they're being fake that's not it at all
it's just that they have like their
vision and their branding and and they
stick to that and for me I'm like you
shut the [ __ ] up
yeah get the [ __ ] out of here like I
know the truth not that they're lying
yeah I want to emphasize that like
they're still being themselves but it's
just a different level of like details
or intimacy that we have yeah it's very
important though just to have something
special for that's why for Muriel like
for the longest time I didn't talk about
her right she's never really that much
on my channel you know I put her I just
recently started putting in more stories
like here and there and then she has her
own like Instagram page but other than
that and then she's been on the podcast
a few times other than that a lot of our
personal stuff like you guys will never
know that [ __ ] yeah and that's it I like
this sounds it's that possessive Muriel
is mine that's my yeah and say that's my
wife we have personal special things
that I don't think it's pretty for
anybody else to know yeah I didn't even
want to put up that originally I wasn't
gonna put up the proposal video and I
put up three months later and I just sat
on it and I was like you know this is
actually kind of sweet and I think like
I want people to see what a real
relationship looks like like this is how
awkward you are yeah very awkward I was
so nervous
you know I was mad that's the only thing
I watched that was yours yeah and you
know I was like this is kind of sweet
and the marital is okay with it I was
like cool well let's put it up like I
think it'll be nice but at first I was
very apprehensive about putting it up
because I think having special things
between me and her makes things more
exciting it does you know it does
because like again like there's so much
of you that you give to your friends
that you give to your audience that you
give to your parents like in it and it's
nice to have like that special
connection or memories or just talks
with each other like Barden I didn't
have that like we would go on trips and
it was everyone we'd go on a date and
it's with everyone it was very true and
it's cool and I like that because I love
you guys but at the same time I'm like
wait where do I stand then in this
relationship like I knew what was a
significant other but I'm like what sets
me apart other than us seeing each other
naked yeah when you mentioned that too
like when we were all hanging out and
stuff right and you know at times it was
like what was my let's hang out right or
it's like you know I'm gonna go eat it
was either you were always there and I
was like oh like I guess he always has
his girl with him all the time or that
he was like me and Jenny you want to
come let's go he's like oh just me and
you I'm like by yourself or it was
always like that
it was always you him and somebody else
or it was the other way around yeah so I
was like oh that's that's kind of it I
was like I guess they're just you know
they've been together for a while now so
they don't maybe don't need that time
but that was something that you needed
it was and I thought it was high school
that I wanted that I thought I was being
very like immature like like I need to
be around him like all the time and I'm
like that's weird why do I need to do
that yeah and I didn't realize like
there's a balance bro like you should
connect with your with your partner
one-on-one and and there's just a
different energy it's a different vibe
you have different conversations mm-hmm
yeah I didn't know I just thought I was
being selfish and he's like not very
well at least back then he wasn't very
emotionally intelligent so for him it
was like well we all love each other
don't we let's all hang out you know I
Bart - is very interesting cuz he's a
very emotional person but he he doesn't
sometimes he doesn't know how to analyze
other people's emotions yeah I mean
his own yeah so he doesn't know what
happens so when he really says like I
need you to explain this to me he needs
you to explain it to him because he's
not saying it to be like [ __ ] you I
don't know what's going on he doesn't
[ __ ] really yeah
and I feel bad because it's frustrating
I'm like what do you mean a hug works
like this this is what a hug supposed to
do is up I don't I mean I'm exaggerating
here of course but like to that degree
where I'm like [ __ ] this is so [ __ ]
frustrating even so she got so
frustrated she would call me or text me
he's like can you explain this to Barney
and then one time - we were training I
had to take Bart aside and like a bro
this and this is why what you said was
not right you need to go home and
apologize and he's like oh so he's not
trying to be an [ __ ] or no ever
he always and I've always told her - I
was like the best thing about Bart is
that he always has the best intention
always and he's always he always without
fails tries yes and so if anything else
my my biggest like indicator of somebody
who is really good to be in a
relationship with is even though they're
not perfect they're always trying to
make sure they're doing right and that's
who Bart is yeah max he always tries
yeah yeah that's quality I love that I
think anyone's best like I don't care
what you did I don't care the decisions
that you make as long as you learn from
it and you change them I'm just assuming
that they're bad right
and if I see you trying to change that
like you feel like [ __ ] I hate that
about myself and you try to change it oh
my god I'm yours forever yeah and it's
not going to be like a 180 turn right
when it happens when you figure out what
the problem is it's gonna be small baby
steps there's like habits like me
putting the toilet seat down like I told
Mary she used to hate it and we had a
big conversation not too long ago where
I was telling her I was like hey you
can't keep yelling me yelling at me
about this toilet seat down